Christiane Bergevin Jacques letourneaux
bonsoir à tous les deux ravi d'être en
votre compagnie on va commencer ça en
parlant de ce qu'a proposé le Parti
québécois aujourd'hui qui dit vouloir
s'attaquer à ce qu'on appelle les super
profits des pétrolières canadiennes on
propose une taxe de 25 % on dit que
c'est un milliard de dollars qu'on
pourrait aller chercher comme ça
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez genre
qu'est-ce que ça se peut bah moi je
trouve que c'est une bonne proposition
d'abord c'est pas le Parti québécois qui
l'a inventé le secrétaire général de
l'ONU dès le mois de mars recommandait
au pays
occidentaux notamment de de mettre une
taxe sur le sur profit parce que les
pétrolières ont fait des profits
extraordinaires pendant la pendant la
pandémie la crise alors quand
j'entendais le chef du Parti québécois
le proposer bon je sais bien qu'on va
nous dire le diable est dans les détails
et comment on l'applique mais je trouve
quand même que on a devant nous des
pétrolières qui font beaucoup d'argent
et on a aussi et surtout des gens de la
classe moyenne des travailleurs qui eux
pay plus cher l'essence parce que
évidemment le prix a monté à la pompe
donc en disant bon on va aller chercher
un milliard puis on va le redonner dans
un crédit de solidarité je trouve que
c'est une proposition qui est bien
intéressante proposition intéressante
oui mais quand on dit le diable dans les
détails c'est comment on fait ça est-ce
que c'est réaliste de penser qu'on
pourrait en arriver effectivement au
Québec à imposé cette surtaxe le chef du
PQ m'apparaît peu comme le Robin des
Bois alors on peut pas être contre la
vertu mais d'abord et même en Angleterre
où on imposé une telle taxe c'était
ratifié ah ben là les pétrolières on dit
on a des obligations on doit investir
dans le développement on doit
viser la fermeture de certaines
installations en haute mer donc qui ont
déduit toutes sortes d'éléments alors
est-ce qu'en fait c'est une vraie mesure
est-ce que comment on gérer ça surtout
que on a déjà des taxes importantes on
le sait de la taxe d'accès fédérale
provinciale ça c'est 30 ou 3 scènes de
plus à Montréal pour la taxe la TPS la
TVQ alors moi il me semble que si on
veut faire des taxes sur les surprofis
on j'aimerais ouvrir à d'autres secteurs
aussi notamment le secteur
d'alimentation des grandes entreprises
comme métro que j'aime beaucoup ont
quand même une des profits de l'argent
pendant la rencontre 2% de croissance
des ventes les deux premiers trimestres
mais 7% de croissance des profits alors
pourquoi le jeu les pétrolières on peut
acheter un véhicule électrique
moi je veux dire si on veut l'élargir à
d'autres entreprises parce que des
études qui ont démontré effectivement il
n'y a pas que les pétrolières qui ont
fait de l'argent pendant la crise le
secteur agroalimentaire bon peut-être
pas l'industrie du tourisme parce que ça
a été pas mal en difficulté là pendant
la crise mais alors moi je suis pas
fermé à l'idée évidemment il y aura
jamais de pétrolière qui va vous dire
que les favorable il y aura jamais de
multinationales qui vont vous dire que
les favorable donc toujours des écueils
possibles mais je trouvais quand même
que l'idée peut-être amenée à sa
puissance mais elle démonte quand même
clairement les pétrolières ont fait
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent et demain
matin vous posez la question monsieur
madame tout le monde je pense qu'ils
vont vous dire que ouf
c'est très difficile encore aujourd'hui
oui mais ils seront peut-être d'accord
avec le principe mais ça vient avec la
crainte que ce soit le consommateur en
bout de ligne qui finissent par payer
est-ce que si on impose une taxe et on
fait payer davantage les pétrolières ne
pourraient pas-elle pas en profiter peu
importe à quelle étape de la chaîne de
production pour hausser les marges de
profit pour compenser et là on évoque au
PQ l'idée d'un Bureau de la concurrence
pour surveiller tout ça est-ce que ce
serait efficace ça cristiane bien son
vise à garder les dépenses du
gouvernement raisonnable pourquoi est-ce
qu'on crée un Bureau de la concurrence
il y a un Bureau de la concurrence au
fédérale on n'est pas mieux de
s'entendre comme pays et demander au
pétrolières d'investir davantage dans le
développement de carburant propre
d'usine à hydrogène alors le Bureau de
la concurrence là moi je les suis plus
moi je suis loin d'être un spécialiste
en la matière mais en fait ça m'a fait
penser quand même à ce fameux cartel de
l'industrie pétrolière qu'il avait eu
des vacances là les gens vont se
reconnaître nous annonce que le prix du
gaz augmente puis là tu dis voyons donc
c'est du concepté ça ben oui c'est
concerté donc le Bureau de la
concurrence ou football qu'on l'appelle
celui qui doit réglementer ça à ta voix
il fait pas le travail donc le petit
québécois a dit bon ben on va en créer
un Québec bon maintenant est-ce que ça
va être efficace savoir mais ce qu'il
faut surtout retenir c'est que il y a
des entreprises pétrolières qui font
beaucoup d'argent et que non seulement
ils font beaucoup d'argent mais que
c'est les consommateurs c'est la classe
moyenne qui paye en bout de piste
Paul Saint-Pierre de l'amandon disait
aujourd'hui bon par exemple dans
certaines régions du Québec la marge de
détails à la pompe et deux fois plus
élevé que le niveau qui est considéré
normal donc vous le mentionnez le Bureau
de la concurrence canadien fait pas son
travail est-ce que juste pour ça même en
mettant de côté l'idée d'une sur Taxe
est-ce que ça vaudrait la peine
Christiane ben il y a d'autres il y a
d'autres éléments qui vont arriver on a
vu qu'il y a des activistes qui sont
investisse chercher son corps et qui
demande à l'entreprise de se départir
son réseau de distribution alors
peut-être que la solution à part c'est
ce qu'on a des entreprises intégrées par
avoir des réseaux de distribution
alternatifs qui pourraient vivre avec
une marge moins importante il me semble
que c'est plus efficace qu'un Bureau de
la concurrence provinciale qui couvre le
Québec seulement bon en tout cas ça a
fait beaucoup jaser ça à savoir si on
irait vraiment de la vente mais je vais
vous emmener sur un autre sujet qui
n'est pas lié directement à la campagne
électorale mais qui est quand même
intéressant c'est un sondage Léger
aujourd'hui qui nous dit que 65% des
Québécois aimeraient bien ça investir de
manière plus durable plus verte mais
leur conseiller leur planificateurs
financier n'a pas vraiment
d'informations à leur donner à ce
sujet-là
quel est le problème à votre avis
Christiane bien ce sondage qui m'a
surpris en fait parce que d'un côté si
on regarde la croissance des fonds verts
là au cours de la dernière année au
Canada c'est passé 18 milliards à 33
milliards ça veut dire que des gens qui
achètent ces fonds là quelque part
d'autre part Desjardins et le champion
des fonds verts depuis plusieurs années
depuis 15 ans les placements en eux ils
ont 11 milliards d'actifs et je sais
qu'il en font la promotion et les
conseillers sont bien formés alors
est-ce que maintenant il y a les stocks
pétroliers qui ont monté en début
d'année alors les gens veulent le
rendement donc le beurre et l'argent du
beurre est-ce qu'on doit vendre son âme
Jacques pour pouvoir faire du rendement
dans cette année-ci là qui est tellement
turbulence
de retraite privée pour les travailleurs
les travailleuses quand ils quand ont vu
du rendement là souvent on a tendance à
aller là où c'est payant alors que mais
à la question pourquoi les gens sont
ouverts et qu'on leur offre pas moi je
me suis dit est-ce que les institutions
financières parce que quand tu vas sur
le site Web des des sur les plateformes
on parle tout de environnement sociétés
gouvernance ESG c'est le principe de
tout le monde mais on dirait que dans
pratique on l'applique pas moi je
connais bien ça là parce que notre fond
d'investissement quand j'étais à la CSN
font l'action a des principes de ESG il
y a pas de pétrole à fond d'action il y
a pas de gaz il y a pas de tabac il y a
pas d'armes puis il y a du rendement
donc c'est possible comme tu le dis
d'abord du rendement et on dirait que
les institutions entre le principe la
pratique demande mais moi je pense que
l'avenir va nous amener vers le l'énorme
SG en termes d'investissement absolument
puis il y a déjà depuis le début de
l'année il y a 20 nouveaux fans je pense
que le changement c'est graduel ça prend
suffisamment de produits et ça prend
cette volonté qui est là alors les
conseillers doivent en parler les
consommateurs doivent demander c'est ça
qui doit faire l'effort et on avait une
question en suspense à dire il y a pas
vraiment de normes uniforme de
certification qui nous dit oui ça c'est
vert et on n'est pas en train de nous
faire de l'éco-blanchement c'est un
enjeu ça quand même Christiane c'est
vrai parce que dans plusieurs domaines
on a des normes on a aussi des normes de
performances par secteur comment moi je
sais s'il y a 20 produits que le produit
a est meilleur ou inférieur alors je
pense que l'index doit se développer la
connaissance puis dans un portefeuille
diversifié qu'on devrait avoir
différentes catégories d'investissement
il nous reste pas beaucoup de temps mais
je veux quand même vous entendre sur
cette nouvelle selon laquelle ça
s'améliore pour les grandes artères
commerciales taux d'inoccupation qui est
en qui est en baisse dans la plupart des
grandes villes est-ce que ça vous est
surpris non après la covid je pense que
les goûts les gens goût de sortir donc y
compris resto un magasin mais sur le
moyen long terme je pense que ça va être
difficile parce que l'achat en ligne on
l'a vu de sa littéralement explosé avec
la covid je pense que les chiffres
d'affaires d'Amazon et des autres sont
encore là pour le démontrer puis il y a
des transformations aussi des artères
commerciaux moi j'ai des amis qui ont
des commerces sur la rue Saint-Hubert
qui nous disent qu'aujourd'hui c'est
plus difficile de faire commerce parce
que
il y a peut-être des gens qui vont pas
m'aimer mais quand même ça c'est
beaucoup amélioré
des commerçants souvent qui vendent à
des gens qui vivent en banlieue donc et
c'est pas nécessairement la communauté
locale qui consomme plus Saint-Denis la
même affaire donc oui c'est une bonne
chose pour l'environnement mais pour le
commerce
moi j'avais tout près de la rue
Saint-Denis durant trois étés on a eu
des hamac alors je pense quand les
voitures et les hamac je préfère les
voitures parce qu'il y avait pas de
place de stationnement c'est une
initiative de la Ville alors ça peut
aider les commerces et c'est bien qu'il
y ait des ventes et des rues
piétonnières de temps en temps mais
vendredi dernier la rue Saint-Laurent
était fermée restaurant où j'allais nous
disait ben on a des annulations parce
que les gens peuvent pas stationner à
une distance raisonnable alors
l'équilibre mais c'est une bonne
nouvelle ça s'améliore oui ben
souhaitons maintenant effectivement que
ça dure avec tous les autres défis
inflation commerce en ligne qui est pas
prêt disparaître toujours intéressant de
vous recevoir merci beaucoup à tous les
deux et à très bientôt